what I want to do as we have a look at
this guy is to think about this
situation because what I love about it
is some of them questions we've had a
look at are obviously exponential growth
indicate you have a population in the
way they describe it is it's just it's
just skyrocketing you know the bigger
the population is like CMMS the faster
it grows or we talk about decay the
smaller the radioactive mass becomes the
slower that it decays so those are sort
of obvious situations this one though
here is the scenario hopefully you've
had a bit of time to read that
introductory paragraph but this is all
that's going on right you got a tank of
water I think they say there's some
propeller or something in there to make
sure it's evenly mixed and saltwater is
going in it starts completely pure no
salt at all they put in a salt solution
and then they also siphon it out
okay so salts going in it mixes up and
then the mixed amount goes out now at
least maybe this is a indicator of how I
didn't do senior science and in any way
shape or form but when I think about
that would I listen to that I like
exponential growth and decay it doesn't
sound like that at all but as we go
through and it's you can look at the
question one of the reasons it's so long
is there actually going to help you
through this this scaffolding it very
very closely for you as we go through
the question and just work through the
equations you will see unavoidably
exponential growth the decay is the
model for a situation like this right so
let's unpack it all together in the
diagram a take initially contains a
thousand liters one thousand liters of
pure water salt water begins pouring
into the tank from a pipe and a staring
blade ensures that it's completely mixed
with the pure water I guess they just
point that out to say you know salt
water goes in that salt water might take
some time to get down to the bottle and
set bottom and settle if there wasn't
some kind of mixing happening so what's
going out is is mixed up it's it's
including whatever salt was put in at
the at the beginning a second part draws
the water and salt water mixture off at
the same rate so there is always a total
of a thousand liters
the tank so we have that there part a if
the saltwater entering the tank contains
two grams of salt per liter and is
flowing in at the constant rate of W
liters per minute W for water I guess
how much salt is entering the tank per
minute so let's start by writing down
some important information this is Part
A they give you two pieces of
information and they very simply want
you to combine them together but what I
want to emphasize to you as we go
through this is let's let's use some
words here there are going to be a lot
of numbers and letters flying around and
we don't just want a series of
disconnected variables and equations
okay so the first unit talk to us about
is the salt right now what do they tell
us about the salt in terms of its
quantity have a look you tell me two
grams they tell you there's two grams of
salt per liter okay so this is really
important right I want to make a like
very carefully watch for all of my units
here because as we remember from related
rates of change that's kind of one of
the things that makes this question a
little bit tricky the units that you
have are really helpful so you know
exactly what's actually changing okay
there's the salt piece of information
and then they tell you a piece of
information about the water flowing in
what's it's right yeah W liters per
minute and again watch now if you just
sort of look all the way down I think to
the very last part of this question you
start seeing they tub they talk about
hours did you notice that okay and
hopefully you've been maybe tripped up
sometime in the past week or so when
they change the units on you and don't
say anything about it okay so I'm going
to very consciously point out what time
unit we're talking about what's the
actual question yeah good we've got how
much salt in terms of concentration
we've got how much water in terms of its
speed going in so what I'm looking for
is the salt and how much it's flowing in
does that make sense so you can see I'm
very carefully described everything so I
don't just have like this is salt and
that's salt there's gonna be another
salt later for salt going out so I want
to very carefully describe
what's happening okay the softer Wien
what kind of rate is that going to be
one of the unit's going to be salt is
measured in its measured in grams okay
so it's gonna be something grams per
what time unit make sense at the moment
minutes we run it'll stay with the time
unit they've provided okay so you can
see see how this is per liter and this
is liters per time unit right we're just
taking these two rates and we are
multiplying them right when you combine
them together by multiplication you can
see the leaders they just cancel out
yeah what we multiply the two numbers
when we get to and W 3 w happy with that
so that was not I was not complicated
but I wanted to make sure we understood
what was going on and then you set that
out in such a way great Part B it says
if there are Q grams of salt in the tank
at time T just pause there if there are
cue grams why are they calling that Q
around the same number well in this
situation the amount of salt in the tank
it's constantly changing right and
that's actually in the situation we're
most interested in so this has got Q
grams of salt that's what Part B is
telling us okay if there are Q grams of
salt in the tank at time T how much salt
is in one liter at time T okay so here's
the way I'm going to write this
I've got Q grams of salt in the entire
tank how big is the tank it's a thousand
liters right 1000 liters of water now
this is what's in the tank at any given
time so I'm going to write in tank right
so you got the amount of salt in the
water in the tank
you've got the amount of the salt of the
water going in and later on I'm going to
have the amount of salt going out can
you see how many different things it's
easy to muddle up if you're not
carefully describing what's happening
okay what was the question again like
this is the information they gave us
what do they want to know we carefully
have a look
the question says how much salt is in
not a thousand liters but one liter in
the tank okay so this is the this is the
rate all I need to do if I want to go
from a thousand liters to one is divide
everything by a thousand right so that's
same rate if I divide this by a thousand
I'll get one liter of water in the tank
and over here I'm gonna get Q over a
thousand and the grams is just that's
just the unit right so that's how much
salt is in every individual leader that
makes sense yeah so you see they really
are scaffolding this super slow for you
but there's a lot of quantity like every
single line on here says a lot of
information okay Part C hence write down
the amount of salt leaving the tank per
minute now I haven't said anything about
the amount of water if I have a look at
the board the amount of water going out
of the tank at leasts not explicitly but
how can I use the information I have
here to know how much water is going out
setting in pop a bill out of him okay so
the amount of water going in which we've
established is W liters per minute has
to be the same as the amount of water
going out because which part of the
information in the question tells us
they have to be balanced look look back
right at the right at the beginning
before the questions even begin right do
you see it says a second pipe draws the
water and salt blah blah blah out so
that there is always a total of a
thousand liters so this doesn't change
does that make sense so what's going in
has to come out as well okay so if
that's the case there's water flowing in
at W liters per minute there's water
flowing out at W liters per minute so
how much salt is being taken out if I've
got my redneck water flow morning okay
water flowed out is w liters per minute
compare that to the immediately previous
line and I combined these two together
yeah every liter of water that's in the
tank is what's going out right so every
liter of water has this much salt in it
but you're taking out W liters okay
so therefore the salt that's flowing out
again I'm going to turn this into grams
per minute by multiplying these two
rates together just look carefully at
the units grams leaders leaders minute
do you see how the the liters are going
to cancel if you want to treat them like
fractions so I'm going to get what's
alphabetical qw on a thousand are you ok
with that
units are going to be in this is salt so
its measured in what's not measured in
grams thank you very much and it's a
rape so that's why I've got permanent
okay happy so far